what is up everyone how's it going happy
Tuesday Tuesday oh man it sounds so
crispy what is it oh yeah how's it going
everyone hope you're having a great day
we are chillin call of duty war zone is
out and there's actually a lot to unpack
when it comes to what is involved in war
zone because it's a little bit different
than previous Call of Duty you know was
a blackout blackout yeah not too
different but like just a little bit
kind of all the right ways right it's
still very like comfortable to play if
you've been playing modern warfare at
all exactly it's just like a big
expansion of multiplayer
we've been playing I've been playing
this morning purchase head a little bit
this is a part of what we're gonna talk
about back struggles so Richie here he's
been playing a little bit I did not own
the game originally on my ps4 I had it
on xbox but warzone is actually
free-to-play it's its own standalone
thing so you guys don't own call of duty
modern warfare don't worry about it he's
free 99 baby and play however the thing
it will cost you is a few hours of your
life because my update dial is 99 gigs
it's 99 gigs and I could not miss will
prorate yeah it's still downloading
right now so let's see if it finishes
and I can join Ritchie we're gonna watch
Ritchie play along with Ben in a little
bit and then I'm gonna try to hop in
once my download finishes but there's
also some other really cool things about
warzone that I'm really interested in
seeing that I have not seen yet which is
the Gulag you haven't seen it yet okay
you're in for a treat because it's
pretty funny it's pretty cool if you
don't know what the gulag is it is kind
of war zones work around to respawning
you can obviously buy your teammates
back in if you have the money to do so
but during a certain duration of the
game you can actually die and then go to
the gulag and then fight in a 1v1 knife
fight for your place back in the game
they actually included guns I thought it
was just nice and like a fist fight to
the way it was posted about in the blog
but there is it basically turns into a
1v1 randomly generated gun match usually
sidearms then is with us and for anybody
who does want to get more of this
information we have two sources right
now one on gamespot comm linking it and
you know what I'm just gonna tell you
everything you kind of need to know
today in terms of what time which
already past and cross play cross
progression the big download from the
game play go and check it out if we're
eating isn't your thing which you know
it's like that sometimes then you can
also check out our everything you need
to know in under four minutes video that
we have on YouTube right now I've also
linked that if you want to check it out
thanks to Tony for that
yeah that's the TLDR pretty much yeah I
edited though so I could I can confirm
that the information is quality
definitely check it out it would be
super awesome you know to have your eyes
support you guys are obviously already
here supporting so we're gonna hop into
much very very soon but first things
first I want to know I see you guys have
already been in the chat waiting yeah
what are you the most excited about for
warzone is it just because it's a br and
that's been all the rage lately or is
there something in particular that you
guys are looking forward to you know
aside from that massive download yeah a
lot of people here in the chat are
singing it can't play it's too late or
from other parts of the of the world let
us know how the how else it's going for
for everybody in the chat looks like
it's out for us but maybe not for
everyone or like it's too late and
you're about to go to bed or the updates
taken too long let us know geez sounds
like another Activision struggle but
it'd be like that you know it's a you
can't you gotta expect that with a
what's it called the battle royale map
like it's it's already included in the
game code which is why if you have it
already it didn't take that long to
download if you have modern warfare but
it's free there's gonna be a lot of
people jumping in it for the first time
and it's gonna take a while to download
so glad you're here with us so you can
join me in my pity party because I'm
also waiting for my yeah then you can
jump in our game there's also a second
mode called plunder I haven't started it
yet but it's it's sort is sort of
similar to better way out except you got
it the point is to make money and get
make as much money as you can money and
there's loot crate's everywhere it loot
crate's uh blue boxes everywhere filled
with money
kills get you money whoever has the most
money and I think I haven't played yet I
think you do have to be the last one
standing but it's all money based
whoever has the most money in the end
oh so once you when you win everyone's I
don't know I haven't seen I've seen a
match a plunder and yet I just saw like
the trailer that's included we click
plunder for the first time it plays like
an instructional video but I guess I
glazed over the ending for you guys
right oh good I think we are ready let's
go ahead and get it pop thank you guys
for joining us again I'll be chatting
with you guys and watching jealously as
Ritchie and Ben Ben just left my party
hang on one second why would you do that
but I thought we were friends
it's like just as we switched over to
the camera - he's like might have to
start with Adam unless he jumps in with
some sort of explanation but it's fine
look at oh you can respawn in like oh
maybe that's what happened this happened
automatically just now so that's
probably what happened to Ben - okay all
read by him noise but yeah you guys
normal guy what is up how's it going
King Kai tapas ji welcome everyone all
you guys sending you guys positivity and
love today because that's what we all
need it's just Tuesday man you know
the week is still just rolling out we're
we're here for you it's the middle of
the night here it says top as well watch
this with the volume turned down because
we're about to jump in so it's pretty
smooth again if you've played call of
duty kind of like at all
you'll feel pretty comfortable it's fun
if you've played like apex you'll feel
comfortable I've played both and I just
kind of jumped right into this it felt
fine there's a pinging system there is a
yeah you can ping spots on the map
enemies loot there are random like boxes
everywhere filled with guns some good
some bad some legendary some fully
kitted out so they're all over the map
there are so many doors and there's
there's a lot to explore it's not like a
bare-bones map thank goodness hello and
love from Alaska says no b.s Alaska
right good stuff Brandon welcome back
says where's I'm so much fun have you
been playing yeah did you get you know a
dub yet Brandon yeah oh you guys I got
close I kind of been playing on and off
all morning and just before the stream
started I got the second place I'm going
for that dub we're thinking you tapas
for being you can kill people but it
means nothing
died he's never done yeah never mind
maybe we'll be friends on the
battlefield me and you well wish me luck
you guys watching from Malaysia hey
welcome rage
[Music]
little cutscene that's my character
right down the left looks like the rock
yeah it's pretty cool and it's I'm not
always in front like that either my
character isn't always in third place
oh I'm the squad leader I'm gonna pick
an area let's just go - lets go to the
boneyard
that's Vanya so I'm gonna pick ping by
pressing up where do yell at my friends
there's the marker let's go you don't
jump out in in a3 formation either you
just jump out whenever you want and if
your friends want to follow you or you
know are down to go where you want to go
that's just how it is
my first two matches no one followed my
my ping and I eventually caught up to
them but you know work together that's
how Battle Royale works although there
are no solos at the moment it's only
three as far as I can tell I haven't
tried I haven't tried to poke around in
any of any other setting though I
thought I heard that you could jump into
the match as a solo duo or a three-man
squad yeah I've written it's all your
choice I got a look into the settings I
just keep jumping into matches because
I'm so excited to play you look around I
think bang is here on my six
yeah you can get a see on the left side
it says hunted that guy signed a
contract if he finds me and my squad and
kills us he gets a lot of money
bounty action shoot someone's down there
already I'm gonna go over here I thought
this would be a quiet area drop benefit
oh I've fallen to my death
more times than I'd like today for a
date for a game that just launched it's
pretty embarrassing so you start with
the pistol and swap it out with this
alright and if you look around this is a
familiar map for modern warfare 2
they've been this it's all been
incorporated into Call of Duty has a
bunch of spec ops maps and it kind of
just combined every damn map yeah that's
the map and it's really cool cuz again
I'm already comfortable with it but if
you're not that's ok there's a lot to
learn I'm still learning I still don't
know the map entirely well I'm ping this
shotgun if anyone wants it another
MP
Yona Bob Jones Bob Jones hey Bob Jim
don't have to mp7 no okay these are the
loop boxes these supply boxes think it
for my friends then you can have it
whatever is in there is yours man
oh if you hold down triangle you can see
on the bottom left that's your armor
plate I have two out of three just hold
it down
quit Armour that's it now I'm ready to
roll whoo I like that gun better than
this
what do we got and you need any of this
stuff it's yours my friend
Oh our third is someone I don't know so
he's not a traitor Oh is there friendly
fire no like don't be it like dork and
leave us behind
yeah you will be going down that's
exactly how he sounds what he shoots one
Oh
a special one I'll save that for one of
my friends and I'll take the sniper it
is but I want my friends we got to be
well-equipped come on guys there's they
see enemies I'll take it okay I can't
leave it there
I'll do it later my friends are like
being shot at one of my friends is down
not like this all right here I come
please don't see me doing this you can
play solo if you want just switch the
nil fill option okay I haven't even
explored that yet but thank you who said
that in chat Thank You Brandon I'm not
playing because I'm still downloading
the update as we speak I'm gonna try to
hop in and let
I'm letting it I'm giving it some time
the cop in band know been friends
yes war zone is free for anybody curious
gosh there he is I see him up there
they're both coming from you now no I
don't well here's what it looks like
when you lose we're going to have to
fight for my life I'll even throw you in
the cell
yeah wait your turn do you know how many
like what line you're in or does it it
tells you you can beat up people like
this but that's not the fight the Gulag
the fight is down there and I'm waiting
for my turn right now you can just throw
rocks I don't know I've never hit
anybody
that's so funny alright they're going
for the overtime flag right there I
can't I can't I am
I can't ping him but they're still
fighting oh my god the dudes gonna get
the overtime flag it's over he won so
now it's my turn there he is over there
let's go I'm scared
back from the gulag baby
I died yeah but I'm back he only died so
you show me to do live yeah it was for
you guys you know truth be told I'm
still hanging in there like I I know my
way around called duty but people are
just always better you know that's
something a loser says like I think he
won his match in the good stuff Ben you
did it however oh we can buy them back I
think but I don't have enough money and
I'm redeployed with no weapons just
armor and a handgun wish me luck you
guys Josh said I really liked when he
died it looks amazing it is isn't it
isn't it funny like you get thrown into
the gulag and then you gotta just it's
like a it's a
it turns into a prison fighting movie
exactly it's like a minigame yeah I
think it's really cool we do some
concept great way to add a little bit of
originality to this genre that's like
being you know oh yeah rinse repeat so
many times by now yeah something else oh
man is gonna jumpy but I'll take it over
a handgun it's good I love it because
it's very powerful no good yeah when you
get released from the gulag they just
drop you from the air again where do you
go hopefully has no friends around no I
can't even pick up executed that's it no
oh I don't you know Emily you're right
I'm really glad I didn't engage they're
gonna revive that guy I'm such an idiot
I should have killed them what I had
that [ __ ] we go out here maybe get some
higher ground
pick them off from the top with my
little handgun or maybe they just don't
see me and they can f off you know I'm
saying hopefully your girls yeah you're
definitely not the only one chuckling at
the response up it's pretty great Oh
check it out I can do this oh well I'm
not gonna all right
I don't you can't oh yeah that's what I
was gonna say you can execute them if
you really want to be a jerk it does the
full animation but uh I was pressed for
time and look what it look where it got
me even thinking about it forty sorry
forty second place how many teams in
total
uh 150 people but I don't uh uh how many
teams does that make that or is that
just your individual placing of the
whole of everyone the teams placing no I
thought it was like our squad I you know
I have Google right here I guess I could
google it yeah Ben left my party he's so
disappointed he just dipped the rage he
was like a kid he's like
in Richie no I can't deal with that guy
[Laughter]
another thing it's I gotta I like to
update my guns when that little green
dot shows up but sometimes it's hard
because you don't get to pick what gun
you use so it's always Oh see I hate
that little green dot whatever it's not
like a skin or something it could be but
I have to dig into it but let me see if
I can invite Ben one more time or join
his party this is a new game entirely
are you oh so it uses all of modern
warfare as mechanics but it's just in
battle royale form so that's why if you
don't own modern warfare your download
file is going to be massive if you do
own modern warfare it's going to be
significantly smaller because most of
the game is already downloaded onto your
console or PC Ben is in the party let's
go guys let's try this again so you guys
got a small feel for it I did any place
very highly but we'll get there we'll
get there yeah I mean that's usually how
about a rails go oh gosh is fusing our
names Bennett Chi must prevail in this
BR a conscious routing for us both Thank
You Akash it's good to see you again my
friend cyborg man welcome I didn't see
you earlier how you doing man is that
Vin Diesel Wow now kinda huh looks like
a mix of Vin Diesel on the rock I don't
know I just like his sunglasses I picked
them all right wish us luck friends
looks like we're starting up here so I'm
curious for people in the chat what do
you like more this or pub Jean yeah
someone was saying this looks like trash
no this game is not good it says Raven
and it's a free game you're indefinitely
entitled to make your opinion but we're
here cuz we like it at least me version
of the poor person has not had a chance
hey car says I've missed you grandpa
Richie yeah if I'm not here I'm in the
chat though friend
you know hi from Holland says HCl
welcome hope you liked call duty and
battle Royales we're here we out here
today check it out yeah normally that's
happened like a few times where the
staging area will automatically deploy
your parachute sometimes it doesn't at
all so good thing that was just the
staging zone Ronnie says looks pretty
good
hope you get to play my friend it's free
you don't even need modern warfare to do
it man yeah I think that's the biggest
factor sometimes like these games are
free to play why not it was a big move
like it's a long-awaited move all right
so our friend our third guy is the squad
leader he can pick an area for us to
jump 141 people and 55 squads because
you guys have to remember you can
actually jump in solo or duo or with
three people so you don't have to
mandatory aliy have a three person squad
every time so I wonder if 55 is the max
number of teams or if it's only at that
right now because a few people were solo
or something I'm not exactly sure all
right then if you're out there man wish
me luck
I actually didn't see when you jump in
sorry wait we're all landing here though
we're all landing in the area all right
the parachute is so slow it makes you
want to do
oh man someone's down they're already
moving over here another guys do it too
oh okay don't feel like every single
battery out the most important thing to
learn first is like how to land fast and
like the best place to Linds very true
and this map like it's wall familiar
like there's the loadout and the changes
I'm sorry the lota and the loot is mixed
so like I that's the variable here
they're already shooting with big guns I
have two handguns it's not looking good
guys the whole band is just crushing it
right now I need him I know he's not too
far he's out there though I just need a
better gun now I've to flash grenade oh
no they got her oh he did two guys
coming up here when you ping him Ben I
hope you heard that my friend they're
firing off me it looks like she was kind
of looking any direction I think he's on
his way okay cool
wish me luck I hope I find them and oh
no they got Ben
yeah they work fast guys not looking
good
don't ping me go to the Google bro
although that guy is sick skin wait my
help I don't have armor plates you get a
an RPG there they're pretty common on
the map which sucks well for those yeah
it's pretty funny for those of you who
are just tuning in at least you get to
see the Gulag now this is gonna happen a
lot look at Ben is fighting other
prisoners he doesn't you can do that you
can definitely fight other prisoners but
you can't die while waiting up here your
point is to watch what's going on down
here and throw some free rocks hit this
guy I really want to see that though oh
he killed him nice so he's free now I'm
waiting for my turn to go down there in
the goo Oh Ben's up next let's go baby
I can't ping him oh did he win did he
win
I didn't oh it's my turn no he didn't
cute wish me luck guys I almost feel
like this parts more cool you wouldn't
fire in good I'll take it okay
win whoo cyborg man says cheers it's
okay man thank you
we are back it looks like at least me I
hope I can buy Ben back because it looks
like the other guy dipped like yeah
forever
he did he did which is fine sometimes
you know I just rage leave like that -
how much does it cost to buy your friend
back I think 4500 bucks I think I mean
that's zero well Ben's taking too long
we gotta go save our pennies and get you
back all right I'm still in the ring I
just want a secure place to land that's
pretty quiet yeah r.i.p Ben after the
chapter Ben is there a gunfight going on
here of course I would land here the
middle a friggin gunfight no it's fine
that means they're distracted all right
let me see if I can Oh perfect this was
a great place to land
yeah I mean that give me that give me
that Ben wish me luck man I'm gonna buy
you back if I can I've made 800 bucks
from just opening that crate but I'm
alone and having a vibe closer
okay so the animal boxes does it just
adapt to whatever type of gun you are
using
no it's it's random okay I'll take the
syringe mmm I do need a long-range one
so do I keep mp5 mp5 is really good
though wait that was an m4 cuz those are
overpowered yeah okay I'm gonna keep
what happens if you never went in the
gulag then you're out yeah
like it happens oh it happened to Ben
you can lose in the gulag and your
friends can buy you back if you make
enough money but oh and I don't know
about that gun operation get Ben out of
jail yeah
exactly we gotta bail them out I don't
they didn't see me why I have my apex
controls memorize it boy okay I'm not
gonna oh it's time yeah I was like broke
his armor but just go for the glory dang
it
I can use my oh shoot yep check my watch
I just need a armor up there you go it's
pretty realistic so you're putting the
armor play on yeah I'm dead you guys
they they probably all know I'm here by
now you got this well wish me luck yep
that picked up some money it said later
hundred more dollars we can go get Ben
really there's money right there and
armor plates for your broom operation
save Ben operations they've been it's
now an affair forget those guys okay
there's the pink there's the respawn
station it's kind of far but if I if
those guys is it like apex where you can
only use a station in one time no
actually not that I know but you might
be battling out with everybody - yeah
someone just well these little loot
stores are everywhere I'm sorry I forget
what they're called they're just like a
little uh-oh
there are people dang it there's at
least three people Ben it's okay we've
got this yeah I just gotta I gotta go
around cuz they're all meeting up there
oh yeah straight ahead look see the
shopping cart on the top left oh yeah we
I'm gonna save you been hanging there's
still 75 people in this match yeah the
game's take kind of long I remember this
this met this stadium was part of the
spec ops map yes so let's see if I can
buy Ben yes worth every penny
exactly got you me if I can drop
something here for Ben he can Saving
Private then yeah dang it I don't have
we need guns I'm gonna go look around
for guns okay he's looking around for
- he just landed hashtag free Ben yes
say those FS in the chat because Ben is
back ABI I wish I had guns to give you
Ben I'm so sorry
I'll cover you let's get out of here
well at least they give you a pistol to
start with they do they do and it's a
good quality one for a battle royale
game that's pretty generous there are
sound effects that that loop boxes I'm
gonna keep saying that loot crate's make
so if we hear one it's all been that has
been opened is there anything left over
another handgun goodness you know what
I'll trade we wait then take my take
wait what's wrong one I want you to have
the m4 then now we're ready the teamwork
see these are the high low please also
been interested okay these are just like
care packages that come out of this guy
oh look at that see you help out get
rewarded we're well within the ring -
we're doing okay we just got to survive
we need some armor plates maybe some
cash because as you saw I use the armor
plate poorly there as you saw you can
there are more options to buy stuff in
the store right now I only have enough
for armor plates great nice let me see
if I can drop one for Ben I'm trying to
figure out all the controls so I want to
hide safely over here and drop fire just
a fire yeah and drop a stack drop all
Ben have at least two yeah
triangle I think you got a whole time
I'm sorry it's okay that's it next time
I have to oh shoot helicopter landed on
top of the stadium do you guys see the
map oh I see it oh boy what's in it it's
somebody driving yeah driving it these
Luke sounds like a gun on it no nothing
I know but they can shoot out of it if
you're not the driver two passengers can
shoot out of it just like in ground war
all right wish me luck guys it's pretty
quiet it's pretty quiet are you guys I
have 42 minutes left on my downloads
so I might be able to squeeze in one
game this and if not I'll switch my
controls to tack the going let you give
it a shot because you got a play yeah
it's pretty fun all right so I have a
trophy system I'm just kind of looking
for baddies let's see my cash with
real-world money I don't think so that's
a good question I mean that cash is only
gonna last for that game that you're in
right in SpecOps okay where are we okay
we're fine like whatever money you make
right now in this game it's not gonna
transfer over it's here next one no I
don't think so either
man they looted the eff out at this
place you been can't get a break yeah
you just gotta keep surviving yeah I'm
just 29 squats okay I think we're just
going I'm positive we're just going in
circles now song let me Marcus closer to
the middle here let's go to the farm
let's go to the farmland let's throwdown
we're done we're done just walking
around no daylight savings it did can
sucks like it's nice that the days are
longer for absolutely but uh I'm not
gonna have with them I'm not then
they're gonna fly right over to you yeah
yes Aaron this is war zone which is call
of duty modern warfare is new battle
royale mode it is free it's free for you
to play but if you don't own modern
warfare then uh have fun waiting to
download it like me
ouch Persia has been trying to download
it like all morning if you didn't have
modern warfare it launched noon yeah and
if you did have it already installed it
was at 8:00 available at 8:00 a.m. this
morning so I was fortunate enough to
download it does it feel like playing
blackout a little bit yeah absolutely
you know like because it's like the
gulags really the main thing that's
that's really different the Gulag is the
fun main thing for sure this map is very
cool though it's a mix of it's a mix of
multiplayer and spec ops
it's like one big map combining
everything you've probably seen so far
so if you're familiar with modern
warfare you'll be a little more
comfortable but if you're brand new you
know we'll figure it out
Akash has Popeyes what I'm hungry
do you know how to get to our office
we're friends you know share the world
what side did you get cuz you know I
feel like whatever side you get from
Popeyes tells a lot about a person
what do you get i what do I get I get
the fries and a biscuit
oh no I think there's a wrong answer all
right we gotta move in the circle is
closing sort of on our tails so let's
move up people like to camp
of course that's obvious so I might get
sniped just running across the field but
but I can clap back all right been
pinged it for us god bless you on ooh
got the fries very nice honestly the
fries are like my second choice cuz
fries are are really really good that
seasoning this is so open I'm sorry
freaking out you can't apex slide you
can slide but you know it doesn't it
doesn't build momentum
Gooch says fortnight is dead today it's
not about fortnight for us but yeah big
playwright night but it still looks like
it's doing well yeah but hey if that
means if that's your way of saying I
love Call of Duty and you guys in your
stream then that's cool oh no thanks
how big is the update for me on
PlayStation 4 mine is ninety nine point
one nine zero gigs but it's free it
really want to exercise on different
platforms but that's what I get Ben
let's hang out over here man no
pretty quiet there are 40 people left
and we've killed two people or I have
remember that it feels like so long ago
when I killed that guy who killed Ben
all right
I'm hearing some firing straight ahead
the little if he does know modern
warfare oh he sees movement he sees him
let me confirm yeah I am also if I were
to choose a battle royale
it's definitely apex for me it's just
more of my style I like that it's a
little you know a little different with
the abilities and the Ultimates all the
characters are really cool I love the
lore behind every character yeah I kind
of like everything they're doing with a
with the exception of like ghosts
they're these characters are like less
memorable in this game I mean but um
still it's all about the gameplay you
know like the I do enjoy also the story
in the lore of apex I love apex but I'm
having a good time here I think maybe
because I feel comfortable because I've
been playing Call of Duty for so long
especially modern warfare since like
before launch you guys know remember uh
we played all the Alpha stuff I think
it's cool that Call of Duty added a
battery oh because everyone's so
familiar with called the duty it's like
a no-brainer yeah I'm really happy that
it's free that's incredible
they finally did it okay footsteps the
update file was definitely smaller for
those of you who already own modern
warfare so that's that's a perk for you
guys do y'all play csgo it was been a
really long I haven't played csgo for at
least a year I haven't played in like
ten years
however Viloria looks really cool and
and I definitely want to try it but I
know 100% I'm just gonna get smoked the
entire time I play that game but it does
look really really cool
over watch noise do I want that I'll
take the contract cool you get a gas
mask if I complete this contract okay
that guy who I just killed was fighting
somebody and that somebody is gonna come
along any second now bring it bring it
ready check it out tap love tap he's
right he had the armor on he's scared
yeah he started running immediately
you're going into the gas bro whatever
I'll wait yeah come on Ben really
actually I should point him out to Ben
he was near here oh shoot they see me
now um he threw a Molotov not cool let
me heal up with some armor he's gonna
have to come to me I'm telling you watch
he's gonna we're both out of the Ring
this is not good you shouldn't be
fighting out here he just ran over that
Hill towards the left okay
the ring is currently closing I'm scared
scared to move alright let's go if
there's anything I've learned of all the
battle royale games do not mess around
with the ring storm circle whatever yeah
it's called in its respective game and
do not do not alright what if I get that
contracted completed contract completed
then I will get a gas mask that in
theory will help me with the ring a
little more but I got to be there for my
homie Ben there he is
man we're so open this sucks I think you
guys are fine there's been so many
people you've already seen just running
in the open and nothing happening to
them Ben ping the car he's feeling
frisky man let's do it it's a tear in my
car I feel safe is a vault
I'm gonna run over people let's go
[Music]
all right well we're safely in the ring
let's see how far we can get unless
someone has an RPG they're not gonna hit
me like they can't be like that good can
you do the window I'm sorry but that
would be great content that would now
wouldn't it yeah that'd be great if you
wanted like my personal stream
highlights all righty you guys are
really getting close
there's 14 squads there's 26 people it's
ending here at the castle the elk in the
castle damn four-wheeling all right I
cooked up me get us to a safe really far
actually you made it to the other side
of it yeah now I want to hug the ring a
little more here oh this is this is yeah
launched off a cliff Oh Luke oh there's
that one over there I would run now if I
were you guys unless Ben's got this boo
there's a lot of people the health all
right Ben jump out if you hear me dude
because this the health of this car is
gonna boil oh the ring is coming though
I hard now they know exactly where we
are and the ring is closing in you guys
do i watch b99 what is that B 99 it
doesn't sound familiar to me I should
have I should not have attempted to run
over them oh goodness he's just jumping
around another guy another guy see me
you have the Frog straight up who is
that
love tap come on
so grassy oh they're running up yep all
right we're running if we're running
then we're running cuz I'm not gonna
fight the ring is right behind me the
poison I actually really like their ring
and this one they got Ben Ben crawl to
the ring are they up on top of this they
probably are this is a bad spot for me
and I think you're safe right there okay
you can actually move pretty fast
you can't I thought I saw someone's head
yeah we got a fight Ben
wish me luck you guys were so close Ben
see somebody they got him again oh shoot
I have to run Ben no bend down like
three people did oh wait he was pinging
yeah I thought that they are I'm doomed
I was surrounded man there's a lot of
open space on this map eleven a soft
high-five oh well how are you guys doing
and I can finally look at chat keep
building keep building up its quit
playing building no well let me back out
of this if we were closer I would let
you guys see how it ends cuz there's a
funny like credit sequence for every but
I've got some left for dead action in
there there's like a credit scroll and
the three winners it's like fly away and
a helicopter and then there's a credit
list it says in memoriam of everybody
who died I love it Ben is still here
let's go for it again man Persia I'm
check remains down loads that oh my gosh
the pain let me just set it to tactical
and you play all right you put on a
wicked sensitivity oh yeah turn that
bull ass down for four okay both here
you go
all right let's see
right would you like cool cool and I can
talk to chat what's going on you guys
how about that 11 point one nine nine
I've seen some episodes of that but I
don't watch it like every see I haven't
seen like every single episode or season
or whatever I am sleeping on that show
it has a lot of people I love and I've
just never watched it I feel so stupid
when people bring that out because I'm
like it sounds like a show I would love
but I haven't watched Kosh recommends it
highly I think no he just says Brooklyn
b99 is Brooklyn my man Seth says I'm
actually installing this game right now
for PC here's to you it'll take a while
but feel free I already have
Modern Warfare because then it shouldn't
take that long yeah o Ravana asks is
there battle past progress yeah I
leveled up twice with my battle pass
just playing battle way out it syncs to
your Cod account pressure asks or says
is this game free and fun yes for me
check check dude I don't know says whoa
for sensitivity it's alright she knows
what she's doing she gets the kills like
honestly I need it I need it I play on
eight it's too fast my aim is just poopy
C and mine that happens to me but I just
can't I can't slow it down because I
feel like it's worse all right this is a
staging area we're about to move on to
the game Chris says I just bought modern
warfare hey well this is perfect no you
there's so much for you to play the
campaign the multiplayer the co-op
missions this and plunder which also
dropped today what's with the sweater
you guys I don't get the jacket emo
let's see battle pass is free it's like
free to earn oh wow it actually has the
memes of the area above the area that's
really cool I don't know where I wanna
go
you can press down the center button
like this one to check the map and then
using the one of the sticks I can ping
where do you want to go oh that's fine
oh then you pick where to go man I meant
to drop he dropped it to the wrong
button it's okay I kind of goofed up the
first few times because I'm used to apex
controls to ping anything is up on the
d-pad twice twice for a bad guy I'm
scared I've died too many times like
that already okay
coño commander is plunger free yes it
comes with this update are comes with
the battle royale game if you downloaded
separately I believe it's both both are
included for what oh yeah you have to
hold it if you want to she's got armor
she put it on but you have to hold down
triangle to equip it and let's say some
things not weapons but like side like
cash for sure and like bullets are
picked up automatically nice maybe more
I have to look into it there's an mp7 I
don't want a shoddy right now oh man my
Apex habits are strong yeah I'm trying
to like put my gun away and me too I was
holding down triangle and it's you know
to run faster and you can slide but it's
not a cool tactical slide that speeds
you up
what is that
Oh shield turret nice now if you press
yeah now it's a kill streak you like on
your bottom right there there you go do
you hear that kind of like refrigerator
hum like mmm that's when you know you're
close to a box Empire says looks lame rs
r6s is better you know what I found that
it's hard to pull people away from that
game you may be right I've never played
it though I haven't played a Rainbow six
since Vegas but seed is definitely super
popular and all my friends like you need
to hop on this one's name it's like I'm
already stuck you know with God and apex
some ammo if you want to drop something
down on the d-pad you can you can select
what you want to drop for friends or
just clear out your inventory a car says
shoddy or shouty no no shoddy today I'm
not about shoddy life me either
people are like ten million miles away
somewhere sniping me yeah oh wow
you cannot call me out like that my
empire back at it again rs6 some siege
is better you should play it again this
is well I don't know that's the thing I
never played it I didn't want to become
addicted like I didn't I was with Cod or
apex you know I can't have a third game
to juggle around man but I do want to
try it sometime I've heard great things
what's the cash for says Alex Alex there
are little stations everywhere on the
top left you see our map every now and
then you'll see a little shopping cart
there are there are little stores where
you can buy killstreaks if your friend
dies you can buy for them to come back
into the game you can buy equipment all
good things but we haven't seen one of
those stores in a while well this is so
open oh my god now we're good we're good
yeah Empire are you hyped for
cyberpunk 2077 oh yeah it's one of the
biggest games we're all waiting for the
whole office is hype man okay we're
getting closer to the action here what's
your rating so far out of 10
let's see me I'm really digging it it's
day one so I might have some butterflies
but I'm like at a solid eight eight and
a half I'm having a lot of fun but like
this is that's just my personal thing
because I play a lot of cod it's not
like that wasn't like an official review
or anything first time watcher here says
RG welcome to the chat thanks for being
here hope you like cod and free games
this is free Oh Empire no problem man
he shouted us out for reading the
comments yeah you know sometimes we get
involved with the game sometimes it's
nice that we're both here Arg that
welcome is the campaign and war zone fun
or not is that really a campaign I think
if you're referring to like the game
play game style I'm having fun but there
isn't really a story so much like aside
from that trailer that they had and it
was just you know run-of-the-mill Battle
Royale trailer like there's alright you
got plenty of armor look at your health
you're doing good he's crawling you can
go fast dude his friend oh that's
alright you can ping him by pressing up
twice oh but Ben's fighting to ban is
down Seth says it looks more you mean
tears ah
there you go he's what did that the
other guy just ran away he didn't want
to finish you off which is good yeah but
you might have to go to the Gulag no no
they're all up over here for sure for
sure oh did I thirst that guy did I
actually successfully this he's gone
dude he bran oh it's up to baby it's a
save the two of you
this is why we buy back then every time
because he came to save us instead of
the other oh you got your Oh God Oh she
ran for her life
Oh quick spray is this a male one PC yes
it is and it's free you should go for it
Dovahkiin says I'd rather play this over
fortnight any day oh well you're in the
right place man friend
definitely not titanfall that's true but
you know if it wasn't trying to be I
don't think this game is free it is very
free fre easy free free 99 free free
free free that's all right
oh you're not gonna I'm in the guerrilla
time for the gulag this is what happens
when you die you get a chance to come
back you got to earn it baby is it
modern warfare says been venom venom yes
it's a it's made by the same people it's
the same characters same game just a
different play style so it's not like
you know team deathmatch multiplayer
it's only battle royale let's go we have
to watch our friend in the gulag boos
boo at the enemy boo then you got this
oh I have all the things it's your turn
I know for Ben you have tacticals now if
you want to yeah I didn't even know I
had a c4 to be honest 29 minutes left
okay that's no big deal
where can i download this Gandalf what
do you play if it's on Xbox it's on your
xbox store the Microsoft Store if it's
ps4 or Gandalf call of duty war zone so
if you're trying to search as in like
call of duty modern warfare where is
that might not sure yeah I feel like
it's still probably should yeah don't
look up like modern warfare a battle
royale it's called war zone but it's
free should check your your your store
or steam
it was on the PlayStation Store this
morning from what I understand but I had
Modern Warfare already so it just
unlocked for me if you don't have modern
warfare at all you can still play this
game for free I think on PlayStation you
don't need a like this monthly
subscription but I think on xbox you do
I can't even think of that cuz you have
to pay to be online but I know I
definitely heard that the Xbox side of
things needed membership hmm okay we're
loading up another game Ben is with us
once again ah Thank You Josh josh says
it's on battlenet for PC for you PC
players great stream thanks for sharing
oh thank you
now he killed me with a c4 he hit me
with a flashbang and mini killed me oh I
did you dirty
Akash says Persia set your timer for
your download I wouldn't do that on the
PlayStation it was being finicky this
morning
I like when it said 26 minutes left for
me it actually took an hour yeah one
minute lasted for like three minutes it
was in fury it seems like it's moving
faster than 26 minutes left but you know
what the console knows best it's fine I
think
it's like an Activision thing they might
be staggering the Downloads because
millions of people are downloading
downloading this cuz it's free not like
an update it's free separate game but uh
we got it we got two here for you guys
today I just want Persia to join I know
I'm jiying yeah do you need PlayStation
Plus was that's what you were saying
yeah I thought I heard you don't mean PS
plus for this but it does have a
disclaimer at the bottom of their
advertisement they have on their future
page that you may need online services
or whatever so I don't know if they were
meeting online services as an internet
or online services as an ps+ mmm oh no
limb Jay was having some problems tapas
thank you for joining us it's 3:30 where
you are oh my goodness go to sleep
immediately get some sleep rested up so
you can jump into the war zone tomorrow
okay limb Jay back and he says you don't
need PlayStation Plus which is cool I
thought I had heard that around but I
didn't read it from anywhere officials
so I wasn't exactly sure yeah
but Alex and chat says to download it on
Xbox you do need Xbox cool okay USA
imagine playing on PlayStation come on
man we're on ps4 at least the super
story now that sounds fun that's it is
fun it's like it's already its own
multiplayer map and it was also a co-op
map for spec ops it's crazy
a lot of places to hide lots of levels
of site and it's basically a Costco how
do drop kits work they work like care
packages if you've never played like a
pix they've hit a pix apex they just
drop in kind of randomly they have good
stuff I feel like I could be in the air
I know that's why I wait for the
parachute to deploy like so late because
it really looks like you're gonna cry Oh
Seth is that 79% boy so close I mean
like 12 more gigs so this is where I
would be if I already owns modern
warfare on my playstation I hope this is
better than for tonight because I'm
getting sick of fortnight and hope that
this is a good replacement try it out
it's free I mean it's much different
than fortnight in like you know the
the mechanics but the game plays the
same just you got to be first you got to
kill them all yeah I mean I would
probably say you would die pretty fast
in this compared to four at night I felt
like yeah for tonight kind of took over
takes a while sometimes but I felt like
in every game I've played of war zone it
takes kind of long to maybe just me yes
Dana I probably didn't worried it very
well but yeah you like die super fast as
compared to Bernie but you know I mean
from being like an apex player recently
like people really oh god I mean even
down him you killed him he was the last
one on their squad I think because he
just straight-up died yes you do spawn
with the pistol Michael Moore says now I
have a new favorite cod game and guess
what it's free for anyone just joining
you this is free what is it who cares
it's free but it's Call of Duty its
battle royale called war zone man that
guys up there this is I'm getting
flashbacks because this was an area in
the spec ops mode we're like you had a
holdup and people are shooting you from
every direction like AI is so I'm
getting creepy flashbacks I hate it I
hate this area Jacob yes this is for ps4
oh oh are you guys talking about you you
guys want to team up in the chat amongst
yourselves okay yeah go for it it's free
make some friends here
friends friends I knew you would know as
soon as I started laughing about it yeah
just friends
Squidward Patrick okay good
so when you want to use that just like
in the in multiplayer l1 r1 yo death the
kid is really out here I can barely read
that because his font is so funky
classic gamers welcome back he says yeah
free but it's a hundred gigs are you on
PC it's only gonna cost a couple
hours of your time yeah what kind of
handguns do they guy I noticed I have a
Glock 7 jan 4 they call it something
else in this game it's called like the X
14 but it's totally a Glock they you
know they can't as weird as it sounds
for guns they can't get the rights to
some of the names anymore
some they can but like name-brand things
like a Remington like what they make the
Skaar like sometimes they can't oh boy
they can't clear the names where's Ben
Ben we're not leaving oh he's up there
okay we're making our way to Ben this is
cross-play to you guys USA the chat was
like I have this for my computer and my
xbox does anybody want to play cuz you
can play it anywhere except the switch
yeah I think Ross plays awesome so smart
he's contemplating life at the moment
yeah
oh no Ben are you okay and were you
reading people I hope he's not like
lagging out he might just have been
asked for help yes we are technically
still working Mubeen yes this runs at
60fps just like modern warfare does it's
looking good
it does if it doesn't come across that
way on stream that might be a different
issue but we're it's 60 for us oh you
see the map someone's happy someone's on
the upper floor up there face bubbles
says hey love your videos thank you
thank you and thank you for joining us
today hopefully you like some Cod and
maybe you know above you there's a guy
parachute he's definitely an enemy oh
those were good shot it was great
trying to pepper him a little bit no-fly
zone
what if you shoot the parachute he
should go down a medium yeah you poke
holes in the parachute wouldn't work in
theory should work someone's honking for
the car Oh your friends trying to pick
you guys up don't get as blown up by an
RPG alright man that happened to me
remember in the first game
someone just launched an RPG at my feet
and I blew up all night says download is
50 85 gigs
yeah honestly it's taken me since noon
which is four hours ago
and the internet here is really good if
I was at home oh I definitely would not
be playing I'd be playing tomorrow man
where are you guys in you guys are
definitely within the range taking a
cruise you know yeah just just driving
along making my way across the man I'm
here with Ben his dress that's go skinny
mini me are you guys joking is this
really cross play oh no Kevin James I'm
serious man just because modern warfare
was also cross play so they implemented
that into the battle royale too but you
can go into the settings and turn it off
yeah like if you're worried about
playing on console and like someone
destroying you a keyboard and mouse you
could turn it off in the settings it has
it's been that way for me when I see a
lobby full of PC players like oh alright
he knows something we don't know akaash
that's really nice
he's just like I forget this is Lear
your job because he's so engrossed with
our gameplay he's saying it's like
hanging out with this you guys don't
know how much it means to us sometimes
to like see y'all tuning in every day
yeah and like hanging out with us yeah
like I always try to remember I try to
remind myself and you guys that we do it
for you you know like we're just here
just gabbing away for nobody we want to
stream for you guys
so thank you for being here oh no
classic gamer says I think cross plays
terrible idea in Cod oh no I thought it
worked out it worked
it's like Xbox to ps4 I think it's
pretty awesome right but I do see where
it gets a little crap Oh No they
executed him he's down for the count
you know okay relax bro there's another
one oh you got him he's reload oh you
got him not yet I'm sorry she then was
just freaking out a little they started
firing Seth says oh come here and get
all this loot Seth PC players nothing
wrong with them they're just better than
some console players myself included so
if I see a lobby full of PC players I
know one thing I'm gonna get my ass here
they've heard us armor up we've we've
made a ruckus y'all got that mouse and
keyboard I tried it but my wrist hurts
in a different way I feel like such a
loser when I'm playing keyboard ping him
if you see him always fighting someone
else I think you got a chance you get a
gulag shot yeah yeah it's time to go to
the gulag friends this is
see that's the thing about apex I
realized so much on hearing this the fee
and all that stuff me too I always play
apex with a headset so this is the Gulag
we're watching a fight but soon we're
gonna be down there fighting for our
lives
you got this yep and if this as your
secondary you got this oh there is oh
you got a new it he'll clean the reeds
easy oh man like call of duty 101 there
was done in one direction and run the
other direction
countless Brandon Hernandez says they
need to release the shirt that I'm
wearing you would you need one oh man
I think we get him like during e3 I got
last year's e3 one but it was just like
the cool-looking G oh the gray one yeah
I'd like that
me too that's nice brand new I was
flying in they know now am I gonna die
no deploy what that's okay
oh it's over over okay I should have
said yes
I thought it could - in the training
area the the staging area that's my
fault I'm not gonna say I'm not gonna
give that false information you jump
your your thing will match the PS axis
like video also and I thought you said
something about the - but honestly I
don't think I was high enough that's
probably why it didn't I see yeah you're
right that's probably a thing all right
you wanna me back in there okay change
your settings that's that's right okay
tack the cool c ool and then back up to
8 for crazy
oh snap my download is 10 minutes away
from finishing so maybe I'll happen see
your match after this one yes for Persia
fo news for Persia yes thank you time I
was like it happens well that's a good
way for you guys at home to learn to not
like jump like I swore it automatically
deployed for me like habits like a
certain height I think I believe because
I really wasn't that high up in the air
which is kind of why I thought I'd be
able to survive too much a pegs
it picks I'm like jumping from the
tallest mountain I could find and then
just beating down no fall damage I love
that you know what's going on welcome to
the chat welcome to the stream go
straighter ass working downloaded at if
you have it on PC it's on battlenet
everywhere else it's free look up call
of duty war zone don't look a battle
royale call of duty war zone it should
be like on the front page of all your
Xbox Microsoft what's it called store
and PlayStation Network store should be
in the front maybe not because it's free
and they're like we're not gonna
advertise this it's kidding you should
stream where not only if a new game came
out well luckily for you you can catch
us here every single week
at 2 p.m. Pacific time and we spend all
time with them we played the New Age it
automatically deported sorry please
continue you were doing great yeah yeah
we're here every weekday
2 p.m. Pacific time we played new games
old games on mods we do all kinds of
stuff here so obviously we had to play
this just drops me and you've been
looking for do it so that's why we've
got it going
there's me the rock meets vin diesel I
even have my sunglasses on no helmet
rock
Rock diesel oh my god everyone else is
like geared up with helmets I'm like nah
man the rock is not okay I'll pick a
spot I am the squad leader stay hi
welcome happy Tuesday
that's what we going red yup okay still
downloading 30 minutes to go hey 30
minutes not that long I started out with
a four-hour cue and I heard some other
people were like 8 hours
alright I picked the spot let's see if
our friends can make it there see if I
can make it there that's very far yeah
Akash is like yesterday playing Pokemon
today that's how it goes man there's
always something hot something new no
it's too hot right there
actually it's my spot it looks like my
squad is following me you can do free
look I saw them on the map there's
there's been I'll follow them because
that ping is too far I'm gonna cancel
that wait yeah let's go somewhere else
boy you know christmas has jumped at 25
hours hours oh whoa Thursday yeah Shh
well I'll be playing this for a while
myself oh we did look like a little bit
huh I'm gonna land here yeah we got a
landing gangsta's paradise no no no
that's that's Coolio oh there oh yeah
and the other cooler guy yeah they're
cool need both their names all right
that was not the best landing spot for a
gun but we'll find something and my
squad is here that's what matters I was
trying to climb the wall like a day fix
Isis you know the habits die hard
I'm telling you come on I wonder if
pokemons to have a VR Tetris did ya
99 is one of the best VR games to ever
grace our existence for ISM a to be our
you know I heard about that
what I can i this is the window oh there
you go
no that was just weird can I get a gun
y'all there's a lot of new people
playing and it's kind of funny to see
because they do this watch they go up to
the door and that's how you can tell if
someone's new yeah you just Oh
for those of you don't know I'm not
making fun but you can just kick the
door by just running these first but I
didn't press any button
Oh good-o gusta fair says hi just got
here and drop by to see how the new
Battle Royale
hey welcome Chris it's free if you want
to download it you should we're having a
ball here these site says my war zone is
locked anyone know why
my guess is going to be because this
happened to me earlier when I was
downloading the game
I didn't previously own call of duty
modern warfare so I had to download the
big file and it will download a little
bit of it I think maybe like five gigs
of it and let you open it and look at it
and mess with your settings but it won't
let you actually play the game so you
might have to check your downloads and
see if it's still actually downloading
the rest of the file
protip because I had no problems this
morning but that's not always how it is
it's like oh yeah no problem downloading
it sounds like yeah this whole morning
has been a struggle last time when we
tried to play call of duty I couldn't
download the patch on my xbox and people
were saying the only way to do it was to
completely uninstall the game and
reinstall it and I was like you know
what no and I've left the Xbox in this
room everything yeah for good reason
that's why I don't have this game on my
ps4 because I had an Xbox
womp-womp no I couldn't make up my mind
I got the scar forget it
I'm hearing shots but I'm let's see I'm
gonna climb up here we go
wish me luck you guys the closest we've
got so far was 11 place and this morning
before of course when I was not on
stream I got second of course
oh I want that over to now I'll just
give it to something else I'll take your
bullets he's all red for you
I want a voice act on some of these but
I want to see all the craziest stuff
where are we in terms a we're riding the
dead center of the Ring look at this
Wow okay did I land this in a good spot
oh you have mine work out already that
just means your file size is gonna be
really small well really small in
comparison to the evidence yeah
things like 15 to 20 whoa this is uh
this is a ground war map I know exactly
where I'm at this is where a is if you
go right over they blocked it off but
it's in this area this is where you camp
for a been waited for me oh cool Brandon
said he went to Cod League this past
weekend and it is fun Oh sweetie I know
I went to a couple of cod league events
not last year but the year before when I
was in Vegas it was really cool I hear
it I hear a crate somewhere it's
upstairs I know how to get it because I
know this no ladder
where is the staircase help on getting
out of the logging into Activision
account screen oh shoot if you haven't
signed up for an Activision count I
think I think you can't proceed unless
you make one you definitely cannot cross
play if you don't do that but as far as
playing maybe your hyper engine I've
just always had an Activision account
okay oh I didn't like I played probably
like for a million years but I never had
I think I made an Activision account
when the app came out and I just wanted
everything to sync up but that was a
long time ago my Activision account
doesn't even have numbers in it it's
like hitman brought no no all right leet
I'm elite I don't want to hang it up
here for too long well I need armor
plates yeah but if you're playing ground
war exactly where I was it was a good
spot to hang out come on is building and
silver are you on top this said they
couldn't sleep so they're back no hope
we can oh I want to say I hope we can
hope you sleep but I don't want us to be
boring either welcome back try some
breathing
Sciences oh ok ok let's do this ok I'm
gonna do a call-out for armor press down
go here request ok so if I did some
voiceover lions say that would be like
get your body on the head I would love
you all of my pinging
equipment like carnival barker are like
Colonel Sanders or something I'm getting
too far where I need armor war zone is
the new battle royale mode for call of
duty modern warfare yeah despite how
quiet it looks right now this is battle
royale I just - I just need to shoot
here gunshots they better not be there
better not be harming been I'm too far
from them Wow I started the game and it
said an update is required oh it's ok
that's a quick one ok ok so this is like
a care package basically look at that
nice loadout drop my guns are ok I wish
I had more attachments but you can buy
something I think in this store I have a
lot of money let's see see I can buy a
whole loadout kit with tactical with
perks maybe I will let's do a right now
it's like are you sure you want to spend
$6,000 max in the chat so it looks
pretty good how does it feel like to
play so I would say it feels very much
obviously like modern warfare if you
play ground war this is kind of in that
realm
except definitely not as dense and the
other thing about it too is that you do
have a little bit more armor in this so
people take a little bit more shots to
die
yeah but aside from that it feels just
like my work there
hoo-hoo I load it up and I have perks I
have equipment I have attachments for my
good mess with me like so slow now with
all these big-ass gun and a bazooka
although I do have this in my normal
layout Brandon said you guys to stream
all of their brand enough for me to like
really dive into this are they shooting
at the truck he was down
I heard that scream someone got him I
think the other guy on the hill I'm
gonna buy Ben back now yeah wait um
enough I don't know then if you can hear
me ping the nearest little shopping cart
i I should have focused my shots on the
what a dork I don't know how I feel
about the constant like red pulsating no
me either makes me feel like I'm getting
shots too yeah at least my controllers
not shaken come on man pick me up I'm
still alive Robin hold on Aurel call for
help
Dom man come back baby crawl to him I
don't know I think he took out seven
batters
come on yeah man hey I don't think so
hey hey hey hey hey come on dude stinks
come on rich
oh I'm about to die
geez way to leave it to the last second
rich the lease what's me okay we need
Ben now Jon says nice to see another lmg
lover hell yeah man especially it works
really well on this big old map you know
makes just makes the most sense
good Wars set in ro that was here all
right where's the little shopping cart
it's straight ahead I want Ben back yo
your team e is rich she does not get my
hat oh he is oh he is he bought them
back I want Dan I don't want something I
can't buy them back Wow the disrespect
is limited Wow a Nazim is richer than
most that is accurate
he's doing the most men yo goodbye Ben
back Richie Rich Kumari
he is he is doing the most time to
reload all right you guys are destroying
now try out the helicopter man maybe
later that's a dead giveaway
that's like look at me look at me and
like if you have a rocket like this you
can just take them out so I will wait on
that the husband has only seen one seems
so frightfully use the helicopter and it
was for like two seconds okay yeah I
need their money I need their body I can
so by arty me oh yeah only Ben can do
that you can pay me while you're down
like if you're out it's like you press
up and it tells your players where the
nearest shopping cart is big baller
big baller do I have the care package
what am i doing it's pretty quiet here
so I feel safe enough to throw it oh man
no it I thought that was a regular care
pack it's not a loadout drop I have a
good loadout currently yeah look I don't
need to do this again yeah I'd rather
have a second gun though I mean a second
different gun like this I don't think a
rocket will help me very much at the
moment do I need a drop do I have junk
no I don't
sniper bullets yeah I'll drop them all
people are dropping like flies guys like
at the top rain it's like 28:53 but for
a minute there is just down down dead
wish me luck it's getting closer y'all
and I'm down a man I'm down been a
little Chomper it really is free-to-play
yeah we're happy man for example I have
my game loaded up right now on
PlayStation I don't own it on
PlayStation and it's still letting me
play but in the bottom left corner it's
like purchase model
yeah I'll show you real well click my
screen see this is my screen right now
and you notice over here it's like hey
you should purchase this but I'm like no
I'm not going I'm just gonna glue some
walls out all right I have a UAV
oh it's been back how was Ben back
tonight he may finally cough up the
dough he did like he only has 10 K now
he had 14 K before so he saved Ben thank
you I miss back then there's guns over
here there's a there's a box over here
yes names don't mess with me now I got
that the loadout with Jordans like y'all
win yeah because I won like my first
game and Jordan came in the office and
was like done what's next Oh apex is
better by size which is okay cuz I
freaking love apex so does Jordan
alright Ben is fully loaded with the
he's got the new setup now I'm just
looking for people let's go rich at the
most is so far away this is like new and
old it's new because the mode is new but
it's kind of old cuz my roar has already
been out for a while so yeah yo Richard
the most is hungry yes oh [ __ ] alright
he's here well here's a little bit he's
hiding in yeah from the mat it looked
like he was just out in the field I can
check him out with my thermals and see
if I can fly them although it seems he
pain far away let me move up moving up
chat how would you are you gonna buy are
you gonna buy are you gonna download
this cuz it's free let us know honestly
back in the day
like Xbox 360 they used to always have
that whole section of demos but I'd
download all of them because they were
all free whoa I accidentally climbed up
this snap 42 people 97% I'm pumped and
ready to guess that's later thanks for
hanging out with us while you wait it's
gonna be worth it man
you see the hospital what is that back
there is that Ben who saw him oh yeah
then saw somebody let me confirm that I
hear you bro yeah copy I'm too far I
can't you know like in Apex I can't hold
down triangle to let go of my weapon I'm
stuck running like this if you're having
issues registering your account through
your console I'm assuming here on
console bit maybe try making the account
on a web browser and then signing in on
your console after it's already made
because I would imagine they have a lot
of people trying to create and register
their accounts right now so it might be
slow if you're doing it from the console
you're totally right there's probably a
lot of high traffic on all of Activision
stuff today movement he sees someone
okay I'm ready man I'm ready I have a
UAV what am i doing it okay
where where wait up there
Oh too bad I'm a bazooka anymore but
they're upstairs there's a lot of red
dots around but we're getting Oh
Claymore yeah can't hack it from here
see that was the point that was the perk
of having a fully kitted tier because I
normally you can't do that vanilla I do
it have no more armor I can't take I
can't even jump up there oh I should
ping I don't even have any more grenades
I think there was one on the ground
that's just pistol no be careful okay
we can't leave what if I had armor I
would go up but I'm too scared take the
lead
[Music]
oh there's two of them what if I wanted
to kill him cuz he was still shooting
our teammate but there was a second guy
I only saw one really bad we're in a 11
place currently if I can come back we
can keep going
it's up to Ben and rich doing the most
whatever the hell his name is he's
richer than most he's not very rich
right now though he's looking pretty
bare t this is free they kill Ben I hate
that guy
now it's up to ya immediate hatred oh
you're the only one who didn't go to do
like this yeah now are you all in
possibly I think we take turns but I
don't know yes free free free this is
free getting invaded yeah right now I'm
just spectating the gulag fighting
we respect Oh respecting rich okay yeah
that's not me no one's in here with him
that's weird but he has the wait his
turn to go down there to do the fighting
but normally in this queue area there's
people you can punch come on now it's
down to seven squads this guy for
somebody
[Applause]
well back I think he made it just by the
Gulag closing and people not being there
to fight him that's interesting
I'm sure like gosh I'm trying droves
it's this is not me by the way this is
our teammate who is who came back from
the Google log fight so Jordan he wanted
for us bring honor to us all watch oh
he's gotta get to this loadout that's
all right yeah just got home from work
you might clutch it up okay there's nine
people left interesting class set up
woods
rich oh you better hurry up yeah I was
like this is that bad that's the highest
we've got today hey we went from 11 to
fifth the next exponential jump will be
first
we've still had a lot of fun literally
my download finally finished like at the
end of this last game we just played so
you're real quick um thank you guys so
much for hanging out this is an awesome
stream you guys are really really cool
and we really appreciate you guys
hanging out with us much love to all the
new faces we saw today and the you know
the usuals you're our friends over there
the old extended family yeah we are live
every single weekday at 2 p.m. Pacific
time so come on back now if you liked
what you saw today we play a little bit
of everything new games old games modded
games you know foods are fancy for that
day true whatever's hot usually you know
so thank you guys so much for tuning in
we are signing off but make sure you get
those downloads in and you hop into the
war zone
Tipene up we'll see you out there see
you guys later bye
you
you
you